[Music]
sorry i'm not what are you doing with
that stuff that you previewed us over
the weekend
oh that's i'm either going to get it
done here or you're going to see it
tomorrow
what do you mean oh well i've been i
think i have that stuff i've been
sitting on this stuff like are you
sitting on it because like i haven't
watched it but i want to i have i i have
a lot here's the thing i'll oh how about
i play a little bit because i have to
taste
do you want to taste it yes
i saw it and i was like i can't i can't
call hey guys let's ask the chat let's
ask the chat let's ask the chat
we don't even say who it is yet just no
no i mean i asked look that's why i said
it the way i said i'm gonna ask i'm
gonna ask them and ask let me ask the
chat
chat say yes
please
should we play with what what
what they want me to play yes miami milf
don't reveal it you two closer you know
what what's about to happen what should
we do here well no go ahead and do it
and we'll have new room in the locker
just a bump all right just just the bomb
okay good all right
give me a bump yeah oh
my connect came through big time i got
six of them
this is friday morning
is the day after a
crazy
incident of my
older sister and my brother-in-law her
husband
they're very large people much larger
than me and stature and physical
uh they're
they're built like football players yeah
you can't complain about your other
brother anymore can you yeah because
he's dead
[ __ ]
large people
both taller than the ghost
will the ghost come back and [ __ ] with
him sherman's ghost oh
ghost a shirt that would be an awesome
shirt sherman's ghost do you think
sherman's ghost ever just comes in and
shoots like a big fat load of [ __ ] on the
wall
no i guess my sister is five seven
who cares
so she's like an inch shorter than me
very tall woman
felt like a football player five seven
is not that tall five seven
so now let me guess let me now
the sister is beating him
well hold on we're to find out i don't
know i haven't watched this video yet
physically shoving me around in my room
with her husband both of them physically
shoving me i had to get out of the room
by pushing past them in order to get a
bottle of water downstairs because my
mouth is so parched
from all the dried comments
fondy hey [ __ ] dan i haven't seen you
in a while do you still have your
aluminum foil art in the attic
constant getting shouted at and shouting
he is
parched now for those that don't know if
you go to the rotc clip channels dayton
is so such a great story that there's an
entire dayton playlist
made from beginning to end how it
started and where we are now and every
time we clip date and stuff it goes on
that playlist so if you don't know who
he is watch the playlist on your own but
here's a quick rundown because it's been
a while dayton hypernova is now
35 years old he lives with his mother
and father
he is trans but
he says he's a woman but he still likes
women
his brother died recently but used to be
a boxer and he lived with him and he
would accuse his brother of beating him
in this house he would get mad because
he would he dayton would steal
dayton hypernova's trans name he would
steal his father's credit card for
example to
to buy more dresses because you wanted
to open a boutique dress shop where
there were no prices you could even take
them for free it was a donation you paid
as you go you know great business model
he is trans but we looked this up and
we've confirmed this with people in the
community in the dayton ohio area the
lgbtq clubs and community do not like
him they do not welcome him because he
is so annoying
he treats his mother like [ __ ] he
screams at his elderly father
he will not move out he's been saying
he's going to move out and it's been
three years now
that is pretty much the quick rundown of
dayton couple other things just really
quick couple other things he can he's
he only eats health burritos um he has
psoriasis which he clearly picks at a
lot he likes to hide in dark corners and
mutter to himself uh he loves filming in
the bathroom and also uh he his dad
tries to always get him uh his dad tries
to order him pizza but it's not from
where he likes and then he gets and he
gets very mad if he doesn't get pizza
from where he likes
and
just recently and this is the just the
last thing we saw of him
before this uh he is now wrapping
everything in the attic
in foil aluminum foil he's also nicole
richie's hugest fan he made her he made
his elderly father drive an hour out to
a convention so he could fake propose to
her
i think we're up to date
by these people and it started with my
mom shouting at me like crazy about
using the shower that they just
installed to wash my face the only
reason i would turn it on to use it
was because anytime i use the um the
faucet
on the sink
in the bathroom i get shattered at
because i get shout out by her
same person
who shouted at me for using this uh
shower
to do it
uh
using my losing my training slaughter
is anybody following can anybody follow
it can anybody following yes you think
it's because of the drugs
yeah go ahead i'm so mad that he's uh
clogging their drain
i wasn't gonna say okay you may be
clogging jj i was gonna say i think they
yell at him when he uses the sink
because he probably gets water
everywhere you know when people wash
their face and sink it probably gets
water everywhere and doesn't clean up
after him oh he also has terrible
psoriasis he flakes everywhere oh yes
anyway so
uh
i seriously use the shower because i get
showered at for using the sink because
the sink gets stopped up by literally
anyone who uses this thing it's hard to
say that he actually looks a little
healthier in this in this video he does
it's because of all the showers
listen they constantly accuse me of it
being uh
stopped up for that reason when it has
to do with them i haven't used that sink
now and uh i don't know a year and a
half at least i stopped using it a long
time ago because i got shot on a daily
basis bro nobody cares
but don't you have your own bathroom
like i don't understand this he does
have his own bathroom but what you don't
understand jj is that the his own
bathroom doesn't have the optimal
the optimal heat temperature and
pressure that he likes so he has to use
somebody else's bathroom and then clog
their [ __ ] up
no [ __ ] that use your bathroom your
stupid phone he doesn't pay rent
this is for using it to wash my face one
more thing we forgot to tell people
uh he also gets paid by his parents to
do the laundry which he never does
a hundred dollars a week a hundred
dollars a week to do the laundry but he
never does the laundry
and i guess their argument was that my
hair would get into the uh
drain or something so i started
yep you nailed it you [ __ ] nailed it
i'll give you credit using this shower
instead
1000 points for jj
because there's a lot like i said on the
rotc shows we're going to be doing the
who's line is it anyway thing where we
just give points they don't count but
you get a thousand
drain room
there no there's no prices the shower
shouldn't there be like an extra five
bucks in the chat after a week no
smug satisfaction you get
yes what if you don't produce points do
you lose money
no you don't lose money okay all right
i'm just making sure yeah
yeah yes that's frozen
uh miami melvin connor you could also
have added he still [ __ ] about the
laundry and he complains that it's not
enough money to do the laundry very good
point 69 points for miami
it's crazy because they went so nice
crazy at me last night because i was
getting shot at for a half an hour and
then obviously in the middle of shouting
at me dayton i want to shout at you all
the time i mean we took a like six month
break from you about six month break
from you
and and and i am already exhausted i'm
already exhausted with you
hey i shot it back because it's absurd
that kind of abusiveness to a person who
was getting beat
[ __ ] leave
i spent seven years in this house by his
skin okay no royce no
you leave it's my house rice you leave
it's my house
dude in that there he is it's sherman
told you the ghost is coming
this picture here the eyes bleed at
night
f in the chat f in the chat for sherman
guys come on everybody picture was a
beating
interview yeah
me
six foot tall skinhead x-boxer
overweight by the time he was living at
home beating me a little chunky he
wasn't that fat
so he was even bigger than he was when
he was boxing
beating the [ __ ] out of me for wearing
dresses in front of them
that's crazy
keep in mind we've been covering and he
used to film every aspect of his life
we've been covering this for a while
he's from every aspect of his life he um
never caught on footage anytime his
brother ever hitting him however we did
catch at least three occasions of him
hitting his brother
once remember when he broke a wine glass
over his head yes for example his blood
that was on by the way that was
christmas eve
remember
and these people act in denial and they
go on this gas scene at the restaurant
oh the outback steakhouse scene yeah the
parking lot yeah writing routine about
how clearly i must be unstable and i
still haven't gotten any explanation
from them about why i would be unstable
on any other level just for getting the
local police know him like the social
department that deals with crazies
because he has had to go to um mental
institution a couple times
against his will um
uh but he's not
he's not crazy he knows what he's doing
he is aware what he's doing he is not
someone to feel bad for
no he is aware of what a terrible person
he is getting beat was satan our first
foray into doing all the lol cow stuff i
feel like that is he's one of the early
ones for sure yeah early ones for sure
yeah
crazy you'd have to argue between him
uh kick him kicking it with baby frog
yeah e frog yeah
wasn't a wall cow though no efrog turned
out to be a friend
he was just a character yeah
stupid absurdity
trumpster bob yeah
mind boggling absurdity that seven years
of violence to me is excusable because
they are assuming because they weren't
physically they were not physically
present during most of the instances
first to make it to the kiwis that would
be dating that would be dayton yeah
but not all of them because they were
present during some of them uh and that
they're just gonna have the benefit of
the doubt
why why would they have the benefit of
the doubt is it are they accusing his
psychosis to be hereditary in some way
for me it's not
yeah dayton you're really showing that
bud you're proving it you got it
i'm not you know you know what
you know you know who never thinks
they're crazy
crazy people that's the one thing i've
learned since doing the show and
covering the crazy internet people is
like they never think they're crazy
and i'm not crazy because i got beat
i'm obviously very rational about how
wrong that is and how wrong it is to
ignore that he's obviously very rational
don't forget that he thinks his sister
is racist even though she's married to a
black lady
i'm very rational of mine right now
so despite my opinion your words sir i
don't think that's very rational of you
do you imagine the conversation just
dayton being like oh okay karen the i'm
not racist my husband is black excuse me
exactly
okay
anger which could be the only thing
someone could have possibly even bailey
accused me of david yeah willie go to
the main show please
sir
dayton will always be main show come on
listen i promise you dayton always goes
main show
dayton was one of the first ones brought
up from day wave to the main show he's
one of the first
so yeah absolutely
dayton will be on the main show however
there is no main rotc show today because
it's patreon monday where we do our
movie riff there will be a movie riff
for you patrons at patreon.com we're not
sorry sign up for just five bucks the
net 2.0 do it it's worth it anyway i'm
missing that thank god oh thank christ
i would be so
weirded out if i wasn't a like angry
about getting beat
doesn't make sense
so i'm getting this on video only right
now because in this moment because it's
the next day and i look out the window
and something that i just noticed in
broad daylight they don't just have one
rainbow flag on their house on the um
on the uh front porch over the uh
front door there they have one right
there
in the side window two rainbow flags in
their houses
i i'm sorry why is that bad again
didn't he already do this before
if you've
either that or he's already bitched
about that in the exact same tone
what is
these people have never stood up for me
through all of that and now uh because i
was shouting back at my mom
about
her belligerence at me for using the
shower to the shower faucet to wash my
face
that does not make any sense it's so
mind-boggling that's frustrating it's
like uh i was getting shout out so crazy
uh my parents had them come over to make
sense is using the shower faucet to wash
your face so
that makes no sense like who does that
you're upset because they
they yelled at you for yelling at your
mom for using the shower
for your face thing whatever it is
and
they're
racist oh sorry
uh homophobic because of
a face
argument about using the shower for your
face i don't want his gay skin flakes in
the sink
oh monkey box
um
well
here's the thing
i got some more though
i guess that was some more dating yeah
we got more
i have never given them the taste
two
hmm
now and now he's gonna do it i knew it
in his veins
speculation
for dating videos yes yes my connect
came through by the way because these
are all unlisted um but i have ways you
know of getting them
um
we did i do remember we did the
thanksgiving one right yes we did okay
okay i wanted to make sure that's what i
thought i just wanted to make sure yeah
um
can i
can i
just read some titles
go ahead because i'm not playing them
now but i'm reading some titles
my right-wing dad listens to trump's
re-election campaign after seven years
of a skinhead beating me at home
okay
it's a little wordy but i like it
they're always worthy with him then i
have
skinhead
enabler sister and husband right
downstairs not on speaking terms with me
seven years nazi violence to me ignored
wait what no oh i'm sorry you didn't
hear me okay skinhead enabler sister and
husband right downstairs not on speaking
terms with me seven years nazi violence
to make me ignored
that doesn't compute that doesn't
compute okay skinhead enabler sister and
husband right downstairs not on speaking
terms with me seven years nazi violence
to me ignored
no but but the husband's black
black nazi
[Music]
but we're not gonna get into those yet
let's finish this okay and harass me and
it got physical towards me they were
physically pushing me when i was in my
room trying to walk away from the
argument they said no no no and they
cursed me out
they cussed me out right there my
brother-in-law called me a lot of
four-letter words
i don't know what those four letters
i could think of a three-letter one
a six-letter word yeah yeah
yeah yeah i can think of
playing wheel of fortune now aren't we
five-letter word yes five-letter word
that's what i was counting to
five-letter word yes yo
i got a seven letter word
[Laughter]
okay
we're playing a weird game of of hangman
right now this is how connect this is
how connected we all are as as co-hosts
[Laughter]
we are pretty stupid oh
toasty okay so think of the three-letter
word but add another g
yeah no but that you wouldn't say that
way no it's a three letter word
maybe if there was a few of him then it
could be a four letter word the other g
is redundant right
like him
[Music]
and told me that i'm clearly unstable
it's like why am i unstable i'm getting
shouted at for no good reason by people
why are you unstable hey royce you want
to read that title just a third time
well how about i read this how about i
just read the title of the one we're
watching sure okay today about
transphobia
last night sis and bro in law harass me
physically they adorned two rainbow
flags
beat how am i unstable this doesn't make
sense i mean this is the 21st century
you can't just throw the word unstable
at someone who's getting beat you're
unstable for wearing dresses you can't
you've never been beat for wearing
dresses you're a liar and not throw
bullets remember when i convinced them
for a while that i work for dr phil well
you still do
durant accusations out of people while
you're being belligerent at that person
who's getting beat i mean they are
clearly unstable to begin with if
they're coming at a person physically
pushing them in their room keeping them
from going downstairs to get water
because the shouting that was going on
for uh 45 minutes at that point i think
or something it was an absurd amount of
time of non-stop shouting my mouth was
completely dry parched and i have
psoriasis all i'm all over
psoriasis
which is one reason why i had to wash my
face it's
ridiculous because i'm in physical pain
on my face from the bloody psoriasis i
don't it's not bloody right now
obviously but it's uh erythrodermic
psoriasis covers my body uh and it
bleeds
why hasn't he been in the nuthout yet he
has a couple times um actually a few
times like the social
you know not like the police police but
you know the some police departments
have that like
what do you call it health crews yeah
yeah wellness check people yeah yeah the
wellness track people know him
right the ones who you know when they
come up they're usually females and
they're very calming
you know because they want to mr paradox
yeah exactly cade paradox uh dayton
hypernova
earl
earl
i just like getting beat in the house by
a skin head
he was never a skinhead by the way i
just want to point that out he always
keeps saying that about this poor guy
the guy was a shady guy and he had some
like weird tax fraud [ __ ] that he did
which is true you could look it up but
you know who hasn't had some problems
with the law in front of these people
it's crazy
and anyway i'm getting this on video
only for now because for this moment now
seeing because i'm looking are you drunk
again out the window and seeing that
freaking the at on their house they have
two freaking rainbow flags there but
they're also flying a nazi flag i'm so
confused
yeah royce they said rainbow flag oh
that's gay
that's obnoxious to have rainbow flags
and decide on a neutral point of view
about violence to a trans woman in the
house that you bro no no
they didn't care that you were being
beat up because you were trans they were
happy you were beating up because you
were a jerk your gender had nothing to
do with it
dayton your unlikable unlikability has
nothing to do
with your gender or even sexual
orientation you're just a jerk
i love that he thinks that's why people
don't like him
i forget he's trans like a lot right
until every once in a while he does a
selfie review where he's wearing a
sundress i'm like oh that's right he's
trans i dislike him for so many other
reasons um
so i've been looking up his condition
right
because have we ever gone into what his
condition is which one
uh the etherodermic psoriasis he picks
at his rashes
well specifically
let me just read this part
because i i've been i was looking up
people with hiv people living with hiv
have a higher risk of developing
psoriasis including endodermic
psoriasis which he has and it's harder
likely harder to treat a person with hiv
i can't still pronounce that psoriasis
treatment may start with
anti
antiviral
therapy or
uv phototherapy so
health burritos
yes yeah and also does it specify that
he could only have a certain kind of
pizza
no i don't think that has anything to do
with are you sure are you sure
no it has more to do with um
topical creams oh yes
bring your children to be babysitter in
front of a skinhead
yeah i'm a little bit angry i think and
that's not unstable to be angry by
itself you got to be maybe he's just
trying to be like one of those like
louis black comedians where he just
screams everything at you you know what
i mean
incoherently
belligerent to be uh someone who's
considered unstable and that's exactly
the quality that describes my sister and
her husband my brother-in-law who were
going crazy at me so badly that they
were shoving me in my room pushing me
and cussing me out very loudly yeah
because you've been dunking on your dead
brother yeah they're probably pretty
pissed at you you've been talking [ __ ]
about somebody that they love you
[ __ ] you you
not nice person
i really i'm sorry i pulled the e-brake
i know where you're going yeah
i'm sorry dayton but isn't it every
person's uh natural reaction when their
parents are being attacked to defend
them
that's the truth man he like attacks his
parents like all the time like
he's a real he's not a good person
and i'm glad i have video evidence of
that now and uh audio too that's crazy
obnoxious
yes you unself-aware prick
horrible people this is like the this
was like last night this was the last
uh uh what am i saying that was that was
the freaking what are you saying
most uh obnoxious experience i've had of
belligerence within my family since uh
the skinhead was living here like a year
ago he passed away january of uh this
year
ever since he passed away it was a
pretty quiet year until i got that kind
of crazy interaction so remember i
predicted this and you could go back
into one of the clips actually
when i said
after his brother dies he will find a
new villain
because that he had a villain his
villain died
but now the problem is it's like one of
those [ __ ] shitty villains like in
the new star wars movie like wha what
was that the [ __ ] new [ __ ] with
the scarface the sith lord's name that
guy you don't even have to you don't
even have to give a reference you could
literally be like [ __ ] okay it's like
new star wars thing there it's the new
villain his name is bum cuckoo and he's
uh and he's got like he's like half
chicken and he exactly like whatever
like he's from
the desert planet where you know the
desert planet that ate luke's dad yeah
[ __ ] it exactly
some pointed out darth sherman is gone
now all you [ __ ] have is like the the
black
sith lord from the obi-wan show the girl
that's what you have now the third
sister yeah the third sister thank you
jj you have the third sister that's who
you have now
and she's married to char char pinks
seriously
two very large people who are way larger
than me both of them
right in front of mom and dad go to the
gym i don't tell you bud
who didn't do anything about that they
didn't stand up for me on that one
either which is crazy
that none of these people are of sound
mind yeah it's crazy none of them stood
up for you you're so loving and [ __ ]
likable right
about violence mama my mom even freaking
said down here
after all of it when she was at a normal
tone of voice because she realized that
she was obviously overboard about things
and she didn't apologize to me at any
point during the uh point of her uh
quieting down but she would talk to my
sister down here and i overheard her uh
saying well boys will be boys when it
comes to wrestling and violent like any
kind of wrestling be he's dead he's been
dead for more than a year
get over it
that was not right zombie attack silling
first of all it's not if it's not
consensual to get
thrown to the ground and smacked hit
punch in the ribs
in the face smacking the head all of
that [ __ ] by a much larger human being
that's not wrestling with physical
assault veggies noogies swirlies worst
purple nurples
and it happened a half a dozen times
[Laughter]
that's absurd
anyway i'm done
oh my god look at the ghoul yes
the by the way what you're seeing on the
stairs this is true if you have to watch
your videos you you would know that what
we're saying that is like dead skin
flakes from him
it's really bad guy like he was swept
the oh it's gross
anyway look there's more dating and we
will be getting to it very soon but i
wanted to give you guys something right
yeah that was great that felt good right
that felt really good right